what's up Wolfgang today we got what
they're calling the last batch of
concept art for ant-man and the wasp
this concept art shows Janet Van Dyne in
the quantum realm this concept art is
fantastic but I actually think that it
tells us a little bit more about the
quantum realm than we've known before so
throughout this video I'll show you all
of the concept art that was released but
what I really want to talk about is some
possible new information that we might
have learned and how this could affect
Avengers for reminder about the giveaway
I'm doing i'm giving away a few copies
of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your favorite
superhero so again this art is really
amazing and it's very well done
but some of these tell us a little bit
of new information there were scenes
that were cut from ant-man and the wasp
of Janet Van Dyne in the quantum realm
that we never saw and these photos give
us a little peek of what we could have
saw if they did include it in the movie
real quick spoiler alert if you have not
seen ant-man and the wasp or you have
not seen the post-credits scene for
ant-man and the wasp I will be talking
about some scenes from the movie and the
post-credits scene so this is your
warning
so although we did not see Janet Van
Dyne herself exploring the quantum realm
we did see dr. Henry Hank Pym exploring
the quantum realm in his search for
Janet so in his search for Janet he gets
stuck in a certain place in the quantum
realm where he sees these creatures and
at first he thinks that it's beautiful
and the creatures are amazing until they
decide that they'd actually probably
like to eat him and at that point he
leaves and then he ends up finding Janet
but I would like to talk about certain
creatures that exist in the quantum
realm because in this last batch of
concept art that was released it shows
many different creatures some certainly
do not look too friendly and some look
like they would attempt to kill Janet
but some actually do look friendly looks
like Janet may have befriended some sort
of beans inside of the quantum realm and
it would make sense because she was in
there for
years and years and years so judging by
this concept art and judging by the
clips that we saw of dr. Hank Pym in the
quantum realm in ant-man in the wasp we
know that there is life inside of the
quantum realm there are creatures that
exist inside the quantum realm and
although some of them may not be
so-called higher forms of life and may
just want to eat anything they see it's
certainly believable that some could be
higher forms of life and judging by some
of this concept art it seems like that
is the case this photo right here shows
Janet touching another beam inside of
the quantum realm and this beam
certainly does look friendly and it does
look like there is some sort of
connection here between the two of them
could she have possibly made some
friends inside of the quantum realm and
been able to communicate with them not
necessarily with words but some sort of
communication because again she was in
the quantum realm for thirty years and
I'm sure somewhere along the line she
made some friends and figured out a way
to communicate with them and this is
important because if you look at this
photo right here it looks like she
stumbled upon something and I think it
could be a time vortex in the
post-credit scene for ant-man and the
wasp right before Scott goes back into
the quantum realm Janet issues awarded
to him saying don't get sucked into a
time vortex we won't be able to save you
so clearly Janet has seen one of these
time vortexes and in this photo it
definitely looks like a vortex it
definitely looks like it's swirling like
a vortex does and right now ant-man is
stuck inside the quantum realm and dr.
Pym Janet and hope are all turned to
dust if they did not survive thanasis
snap and we're not sure if his daughter
survived Louise survived we're not
really sure who's survived and even if
they did I don't think there's anybody
else that could get him out of the
quantum realm no one knows how to work
that technology except for Janet Hope
and dr. Pym so how is he going to get
out so in movies they don't mention
things unless they're of some importance
they wouldn't have thrown don't get
sucked into a time vortex in the
post-credit scene unless it meant
something so I'm guessing somehow
ant-man is going to find a time
tax and use it to escape to some time
maybe in the past maybe in the future
and it is widely believed that once he
does this he will find Tony Stark and
together they will figure out how time
travel works and they will use time
travel in Avengers 4 but with these new
concept art photos that came out I think
there is another element that no one's
really picking up on and I believe that
element is the life forms that live
inside of the quantum realm
again I think Janet made some allies in
there and I think she probably made some
enemies as well
so now ant-man is stuck in there and I
think he'll probably run into some of
those enemies but I also think he'll run
into some of her allies and I think
somehow he will be able to communicate
with her allies and they will take him
to a time vortex and I think that they
even may be a key to Scott Lang and Tony
Stark figuring out how to harness time
travel so again judging by these concept
art photos it does seem like she had
some sort of communication with these
beans and it does seem like she had them
as allies and I don't think that they
would have mentioned the time vortex and
the post-credits scene of ant-man of the
loss unless it meant something but this
is just my own personal theory let me
know what you all think in the comments
below and let me know if you have a
theory of your own and of course don't
forget to tell me what you think about
the concept art itself and another
reminder about our infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero thank you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]